now there's lots to talk about in terms
of britain's response to the pandemic
this morning so
delighted to say we're joined by the
vaccines minister nadim zahalwe really
good to see you in the flesh
finally it makes a lovely change um look
it's the government still being driven
by
data and not dates in our response very
much so and
if you recall when the prime minister
set out the road map to reopening the
economy he talked about the four tests
one
is vaccines need to continue to be
deployed at scale
vaccine efficacy we're seeing some
really good data in terms of vaccine
protection and now from
public health england the facts is
working against household transmission
cutting it by 50
3 obviously infection rates because the
virus will attempt
to infect more people to mutate and then
the fourth is the mutations
so the four weeks plus one the five week
period is really important because
there's four weeks of data gathering
as we open up we had a big opening uh
this month on 12th april of the economy
the data's looking good and positive but
nevertheless we really have to be
careful
because what we don't want is mutations
for example
to um blindside us and then have another
spike and yet jonathan van tam said
didn't it you know if
if people were fully vaccinated it would
be incredibly safe in his word for them
to meet up and have some physical
contact all that sort of thing
with that in mind can't we use things a
little bit more for those people who are
fully vaccinated so this is why we have
to be careful i think
the the full quote was um yes of course
uh they are incredibly safe if they are
fully vaccinated so two doses
at the moment only one in four
adults have actually had the two doses
now
we're accelerating second uh doses
april's been second dose
month but let me give it to you let me
sort of give you the flip side why
we have to be careful on this if the
vaccines have 85 percent
efficacy and we vaccinate fully 85
percent
of the na of the adult population that
still is only 72
percent protection so there's still
quite a sizable
percentage for the virus to go after and
infect
which is why we've got to be careful
hence why the four weeks of data
collection
and then one week of analysis and then
moving to the next step now the good
news is
we're not seeing any evidence that would
lead us to believe that we can't meet
the next step in may the really
important step 17th of may and then
ultimately
obviously the 21st of june but it's much
better to be careful
and follow the data collect the data
properly analyze it
and then make a decision then to
we all want to obviously get our
freedoms back as quickly as possible
but let's do this properties do it
safely well in terms of that
there's obviously now the talk about a
booster and a 60 million
fisa vaccines have been bought or
being bored where does that leave us in
terms of
of sort of cross-vaccination is that
going to be
fisa vaccines given to to people as a
booster whatever else they've taken in
the past
so for this current deployment so phase
one we've just completed the over 50s
uh everybody's been offered a first dose
of course we're now second dosings i
explained
that deployment continues so if you've
had pfizer you'll get a five second dose
you've had astrozenica you've got acidic
secondary moderna
moderna we have two clinical trials that
are
important one is the mix and match trial
which we've put
seven million pounds to fund that will
report at the
end of the summer that will help us for
future proofing
and planning of vaccination campaigns
the second one which jonathan van tan
referred to last night
which is the cove boost trial
which looks at which booster vaccine
single shot would be the best
now what we want to do and my focus at
the moment is to give the scientists
as many options as possible for that
future proofing whether it's pfizer
astrazeneca astrozenica variant
val neva the scottish manufactured
vaccine
and of course novovax which works
extremely well against both the current
dominant
virus which is the kent virus and the
south african virus i mean i spoke to
sir john bell
who's on the vaccine task force a couple
of weeks ago and
he was very much of the opinion looking
at the data he'd seen that actually
mixing the vaccines
would give a much stronger immune
response
it could do and which is why we've got
the mix and match uh clinical trials
they'll report at the end of the summer
the booster
trials as well the cove boost trials
will also be able to tell us
which booster shot would be the most
suitable and of course
the scientists will then have to decide
whether you
boost obviously the most if you recall
the most vulnerable uh
to covert we began vaccinating on the
8th of december
with pfizer and then 4th of january with
astrazeneca
so i want to give the scientists as many
choices of
vaccines to be able to use as a booster
they will decide whether
we go september or later in this year or
early next year depending on the
durability
of the current vaccination program
but we need to give them that ability to
have as many
different vaccines in their armory to be
able to continue
to manage the virus and i think we will
begin
by next year to hopefully move from
pandemic to endemic
and treat it like we would do with a flu
vaccination program and the other bit
obviously that the nhs
is planning at the moment is how do you
dovetail a
covert boost campaign with the flu
vaccination program in the autumn look i
can appreciate you're in a very
difficult position because i mean
your priority your focus is is
vaccinating
the united kingdom but when you're
looking at buying all these extra
vaccines so this is the 60
million doses of of pfizer when we don't
quite know if that's going to be the
right approach for everybody and you say
getting lots of these different vaccines
on board
well we know there is still this huge
global problem
at what point do we start to look at
this from westminster
as a global issue that we need to start
dealing with
really important question so literally
from the inception
of the vaccines task force when the
prime minister set up the vaccine starts
with
he gave us two priorities one find the
vaccines
that will work against this virus so go
out and look
and find them manufacture them in the uk
if you can
contract early if they're not
manufacturing the uk and get them here
but the second priority from back in
march of 2020
is how do you help the rest of the world
he said to have a plan of how we have
that so we're the first country to put
548 billion pounds to the kovacs which
is
the infrastructure that's now delivering
40 million vaccines of landed for over
100 countries so
philippines and ghana and ivory coast
uh have all been receiving kovacs the
bulk of it by the way is the oxford
astrozenica vaccine
the oxford team and astrazeneca are not
making any profit on that it's being
done at cost
whilst we're in pandemic around the
world
so we are doing a hell of a lot to make
sure we help the rest of
india has historically been there for
our nhs
many many colleagues who work in the nhs
are of
indian heritage it's really important
we're one of the
first countries to help in the hundreds
of uh pieces
of um health machinery that was needed
by them including oxygen concentrators
went out to india but we're also through
oxford and astrazeneca um giving
the serum institute the ability to
manufacture 70 million
doses a month for india and other
low-income countries
okay look you mentioned the prime
minister can we talk about his current
predicament
um sakia stammer said on television
last night with these investigations
inquiries that are underway
this could all be over in five minutes
he said if the prime minister just
tells us what went on with the refurb of
his flat why doesn't he do that
well first of all the prime minister has
answered
umpteen questions on this including as
your viewers would say
would want to know did the taxpayer pay
for the refurbishment
or not he paid for the refurbishment
unlike previous prime ministers tony
blair i think spent
some like 300 thousand pounds on
refurbishing uh
the flat in uh number ten over time
but here's the the problem for kirsten i
listened very carefully to him last
night
because he did a big sit-down interview
with robert peston 10 minutes
of that and pt barnum would have been
proud of him
he was the ultimate bandwagoner not a
single policy idea for an election
important elections coming up in seven
days time
all he could talk about yeah but come on
people was this question but people
could say the same about you saying well
you're trying to dodge
you're trying to dodge the issue by by
talking about their lack of policy
suggestions
we have elections we have elections in
seven days time but people want to know
what you're going to do are you going to
be
delivering a vaccine program are you
going to deliver a leveling up agenda
where we're investing
640 billion in infrastructure but the
prime minister has said as you said he
said repeatedly i
paid for this refurbishment well he
might have done in the end what we want
to know is where was the money coming
from originally the talk of
you know 58 000 coming from one donor
loans from cchq did any of that actually
happen
well first of all the uh prime minister
has
appointed lord guy who was the i'm
actually the queen's
um uh private secretary a crossbencher
in the house was
really important the reforms we've made
to the way uh lord
can effectively do his job is to allow
him to be proactive
in his investigation the prime minister
will absolutely
make sure that he delivers everything
that lord guide
asks for to be able to conduct that
investigation
the primers have been very clear that he
paid for this that he
also followed all the ministerial codes
took advice and if lord guyt in his
investigation
requires the prime minister to make any
other declarations then he will also
would that so that's a commitment is it
because ultimately as it stands the
prime minister
is the ultimate arbiter of this own
investigation
he could he could dismiss it he could
just dismiss the recommendations you
saying that
that whatever lord comes up with
independently
will be acted upon so this is a really
important question
part of our reforms now allow
lord guy to be able to be proactive
rather than reactive
all ministers serve with the confidence
of the prime minister
he's appointed lord guy to look at
ministers
and ministerial conduct it's only right
i serve because i have the confidence of
the prime minister if i don't have that
confidence
i will clearly lose my job so
ultimately the prime minister has done
everything in his power to answer these
questions
we've got elections in seven days time
labor at the moment
are a policy-free zone uh i worry
because
the voters will look at kirsten i think
they'll probably
be thinking well you know where where
are the ideas
where are you what are you going to do
to better my life how are you going to
give me a job at the end of this
pandemic are you going to
back uh this country being able to do
the vaccinations that it needs which
you know is important to make sure we
come out of this pandemic
okay as possible we will find out what
the voters think
in a week or so well really good to see
you this morning thank you very much
indeed